Hello everyone, welcome back to another video about conservation!
Today I am going to show you the cleaning
and repair of two specimens. First of all,
we have this frog. Look how cute this frog
is. It was on display in the Mammal Hall here
in the museum, in a place where it was a bit
hidden. The fun about this was that the visitors,
as they were walking, could say "What is that
doing there that is not a mammal?" So, well,
when it was on display, this wooden base that
it has was covered in these little red pebbles,
right? So now the whole base is all with this
kinda reddish pink powder. So, the idea is
that we are going to clean this frog a little,
so that it is in better condition to be able
to study it or perhaps bring it back on display.
What we are doing, then, in the beginning,
is simply taking out all these pebbles, which
we don't want. But some of them are in places
a bit complicated, so we are moving them a
little here, a little there ... There it is,
and it is getting better and better, the poor
frog, without all these pebbles that are in
the way and don't let us see what's going
on with the bones, right? Because the idea
of having this animal is
to be able to see its bones. So, we continue
to remove the pebbles a little, and after
removing the pebbles what we are going to
do, a little with this brush that I have in
my hand, we are going to remove this dust
that we do not like at all. So, there we are
removing it. And another technique that we
sometimes use to clean is the same sponges
that I already showed you in the video where
I was cleaning the horse, so make sure you
watch that video because it's great how all
the dust that a horse skull had, comes off,
in the same series of videos; don't miss
it. And there, more or less, you can see how
it turns out. Of course I am not going to
finish it here because there is a lot of work
to do, but it is a first approximation of
how this poor frog will look like, who had
all this red dust and was a little dirty and
was not happy at all, or cheerful at all.
So, another thing that I'm going to show you
today, besides cleaning this frog, is another
specimen that was also in the Mammal Hall,
which is a little deer. I have it next to
me and now I'm going to show it to you, when
I finish getting a little more of this dust
out. There it is ... so, this is a first approximation,
obviously it will not be like that, it will
be much cleaner when I finish working with
the frog, but, as a first step, the idea is
to remove all this that was next to the frog,
which we don't want. So, at least now the
bones are not at risk, and we can continue
cleaning this specimen, calmly.
Let's now talk about this little deer, which,
as I told you, was also on display in the
Mammal Hall. We are going to leave the frog
on one side... and what happened to it during
the time it was on display is that one of
its fingers came off. And here you can see
that I collected that finger. There is the
little finger I collected. So, the idea, what
are we going to do today. First, we are
going to take out a little bit of these pebbles
that are here because they are in the way.
See how the leg moves? It is loose. We are
going to put a little protection here. And
we are going to use an adhesive that we refer
to as "archival", a conservation adhesive,
and what we are going to do is use it, slowly,
with this little finger. Here you can see
it. We are going to wet the brush and put
the adhesive on the finger. And now, slowly,
very carefully, we are going to stick this
finger back. There you have it, how the deer
looks with its little finger stuck back on.
Well, the idea was to show you a bit of the
conservation work that we do here at the museum,
with a little cleaning and with a little repair
of some specimens. As I told you, we also
have a preventive conservation video, don't
miss it. And in addition, we have another
video about cleaning and repairing feathers
from taxidermy animals. Thank you very much!
(Music)